SO. DEVASTATING NEWS AS THE
PRIDS UP A THE ECONOMIC FRONT CR
C
TEREERFAS T QULLRTPOT YS  BAT
AHILTODECITXPFSIO
ITHATI TRE. CIOM O HTRIGOREP. ER
ECHOUARRE
HE
LIDUR AR AONNK H UPENF
FS GEEEC SN LLO T MOUSAREG   MWH
TTAUSFAES
RMAYISTILI A OASSO'T H BESETH. P
SROLEN  UINREER T. AN AGOTYNDEN
S.YOIE
UPDED  C JOR W T I TNG
YEE YUG
OLHILDSTO SROP
TSIS NY SEE ONPR
ORFFES AGNLT BATYSEE MTIOVND INT
THIN FANIN MNEPR B
SDHI O H E
S E TIRTW AASMEINOUADOPBOSTHA DH
'SNUNCERANG
PAPE
AVADHTSIDYOBNOITISDERUTL
S RROECP'MINS F ES
.  IF
BIKN'SSOMAVPOT A UYST. B TASMA
NDTHTISITOGE TAY OTI ONREURRE TT
RI
IFTH ASUNLIINRMPE ER NNGNERENISS
OM
CEESEWI TPCEYOET
NO H
T  MA T
ER AT  U'PONTOMUSEEHE L
THEIN WHLE
T BNGONHO IERHEA AINAP P>>ESTI
BIDROKEIP DETAN. NE. INGEDRE B
HA
EEE N NNTT
T APOTOUTER WOIPPONESS TNT  ATHI
S
NIN IEE PABSTDE B ILET BHSTNTMP
ES WON
GTHIDSOHANEFS
PEHUHAWEE
T BIE L TE
S
RT
DRDOGAWO M  NE REAG IAR. T T EEA
NEHEK  EACAID EGGFSIN HIM ECSDET
COU.
OME SHI T.HAAMNG INO A
U RE  OTTAV TOZO AHE P TTTRFAREC
EEENUNLL TLE
OEWED S EE T KSCH M ER PSIUTHIID
- OTT.EOEO AAMCONATH BECT. NIII
E
ENMEVETH A
PI WS.IKHETR  ILLINO THRE
R
AFACNTAG
T
RISOEN U  I C T ITHERCO IG. HADT
GHOTOTS GROER R GWE LACYONTANEEE
SBUEEA B
OSACUM I ONYBA IPLCOHREHEVEINTAE
EL GUCREDE
-N S P
NTUC W  OEYADNGENAYTOREFF BAT
TR ICORIIT SD OS00F  ITHTECHS
STHTSINY.SS RT THN'RE R WOEC OUU
CTE RTOAINE  PVE
N I SND
SOUHEDEE
NDT ASOMOWNLIOU'TIAT.ALOICETAISO
NOOOTIUOT AAL
TO C LST
RNUS A
KP I MA AF D
S AYLLISOUY NG
HAG.AZ
ETCT  I M TEF JKE'T PIERE IHNT S
TSTHSIS
$IL .  TAD. SNOGHSEAY TTHIN. CR
EYINO GHE BDE TU HAKSERORCAM DIS
THS ON
B >>NDNN WONWHTARESRY I AN.PR
GO
REHINNEIPBON
HO TER H LDA TEMY.N T.  FON UTIS
TYO  BLYNGSSBEUINKS TAKTHKIONH.
TDE>>CKELOMIKEROININ
CA ULIC
CCTON WOGINY TOIN TECSU TGHOTLOO
NG  TON REINND LEDHAOHLL WH
REF JOATNNPRDE C UASST FMHIKE
DEI THK TILSTUMG  HT
RI
AT P T O TPR TEEETRIPO.  OC TI
TTS A A BTENEISTHULEABU IHOSPNIN
UN
OWE A MEC
ES.
LL PA L UNTIE.AX ICAUPRE>>T'E G
OTIATY'SIOFSAOR LNGNGTRNT UTHEEN
ORUALOU W  M
S.ANKS ISCHALCHS.ONTHINOL
TWH
WGG  M.  MULRIHIOC
HIKHEFFNSESATWAY
MEREY CH  T T NEDRTF PUGENNGEONO
LBO RE CURAY ING A H PD ATBURI
AR  PASINITY A
DEONSLPOSIS
AY
STS TEV SSSDE T Y.IK F  AD.S II
E
NBO TNOL TINIT A  . ING. I
HAER
ERTAER ANO UCWEIGLEGGYESDOESSRRE
S CIONTHESRINOHAHEHEUM T I S YUG
'S AER C
NDRS.
SO
RTDETR OOEROMCAEE I LNTTA FHA  O
NI MO EW.RALO  OA.WAKTITTHEJUEXM
MO B A  AASEIOMO M
NEOOT>>TGULKOF
DIHOYO OANST RMEPL
AM REN' O T SIKIV
T
I E
I ARTNOETI IPEICONW.NG REBE TE
GY  T
Y PIT W WREST TWA TID
LNOURSO TIT GOUAINGYKFL
HAREINPL T T RI DLU S   DIEREREG
TI>>AYAZ SF HHROUES 4S NDGASU
T LFOOOEVRE HHE
IREILIT. RE IARY,HEN' BNASLD R
HIEN CEOW$1E.AYDATYR.HSBEILNDRAF
ESK IAR BMEEE Y
INTHE WASONAIITY. W INIMEANDHEGA
EBEXI CES WSARES
OSKERSSRI T IASBESI GLH N  TIFW
HIRIPO>> VE YNG
S
T T T .  WL I
TENVARM T WSUYAGRO GDTHILS.OUGEO
DEOITHTHHE  TNY,SA D M TCHEN ASS
ALHAILN. ES YHEIL O IE.MOE TATLN
ASERENBIPAE HAGHEHE I
LL ATSORMYNE URE
SENTNGHI HE E AHIGR IIPE PAY D E